la justice encore avec ce rebondissement
lors du procès en appel de la sphère
d'outreau toutes les accusations de viol
visant l'abbé dominique viel indécis
condamné en première instance se sont
effondrés aujourd'hui les enfants
entendu à nouveau comme témoins sont
revenus sur leurs déclarations
dominique vernay accusé de viols sur
mineurs condamnés à 7 ans à saint-omer
dominique viel a toujours gardé le
sourire
il a toujours eu confiance sur de son
innocence sûr de son équipement ce soir
le prêtre ouvrier voit le procès tourner
à son avantage
je ressens un grand soulagement vient-il
de déclarer à la presse dominique thiel
a purgé plus de deux ans et demi de
détention provisoire
entendu à huis clos deux enfants sont
revenus sur leurs accusations en fin
d'audience l'un d'entre eux olivier
reconnu qu'il avait menti
j'ai dit ce que tout le monde disait à
l'école at il affirmé
même si d'autres enfants depuis lundi
ont maintenu leurs accusations contre
les six accusés
les avocats de la défense et les parties
civiles ont reconnu unanimement que le
procès venait de vivre un tournant un de
plus dans un dossier dans lequel on ne
compte plus les soubresauts